be seated
after years of legal battles the
international court of justice ordered
colombia to immediately seize naval and
fishing activities in waters that the
court ruled belonged to nicaragua
by interfering with
fishing and marine scientific research
activities of
nicaraguan flag or nicaraguan licensed
vessels end with the operations of
nicaragua naval vessels in the republic
of nicaragua's exclusive economic zone
the republic of colombia has violated
the republic of nicaragua's
sovereign rights and jurisdiction in
this maritime zone
the ruling is the latest in a
century-old dispute between the two
countries over a number of islands in
the western caribbean that are home to
one of the world's largest coral reefs
nicaragua filed this case in 2013
after a previous 2012 ruling confirmed
colombia's sovereignty over the main
islands but reduce the expense of sea
belonging to colombia giving nicaragua
access to underwater oil and gas
deposits as well as fishing rights
but then colombian president juan manuel
santos said colombia could not agree to
changing its territorial boundaries
without a bilateral treaty a treaty that
has never been pursued
colombia's responsibility despite the
court orders colombia's current
president ivan duque insists it will not
allow nicaragua to limit any of what he
says or colombia's rights
we will defend colombia's highest
interests in the caribbean sea there is
no room for hesitation or ambiguity
faced with this kind of responsibility
some political observers say consecutive
colombian governments have tried to
avoid reaching a settlement fearing the
political consequences of any perceived
secession of sovereignty so the only way
to put an end to this today is via a
bilateral negotiation and the decision
today actually makes it quite
even more difficult to continue
postponing that now it remains to be
seen how the two countries sit down
given existing tensions between the
governments of nicaragua and colombia
colombia said it will not negotiate with
the government it considers a
dictatorship but the court's ruling are
final and legally binding which might
force them to do so potentially bringing
to an end this long-standing dispute
alessandro ampietti al jazeera bogota